abbiamo deciso di presentarci in un modo
banale
io sono una donna
io sono un uomo ma va io sono un
autistico davvero banalmente inizieremo
con una citazione canto nella risposta
alla domanda che cos'è l'illuminismo
l'illuminismo el'uscita dell'essere
umano da uno stato di minorità di cui
egli stesso è colpevole minorità
el'incapacità di servirsi della propria
intelligenza senza la guida di un altro
colpevole e questa minorità se la sua
causa
non dipende da un difetto di
intelligenza ma dalla mancanza di
decisione e del coraggio di servirsi di
essa senza essere guidati da un altro
abbi il coraggio di servirti della tua
propria intelligenza
questo dunque è il motto
dell'illuminismo cresciamo con l'idea
che giunti ad un punto della nostra vita
qualunque sia il nostro desiderio più
intimo o quali che siano le nostre
fantasie deve arrivare il momento in cui
dobbiamo decidere quale sarà la nostra
strada oppure vendiamo fortemente
consigliati sulla direzione da
intraprendere
artista no influenze esploratori di
terre selvagge ingegnere lavora produci
consuma posso rimanere single fatti una
famiglia anche se non hai tempo aspetta
40 anni e va in pensione sperando di non
rimanere vittima della riforma
pensionistica sbagliata
c'è chi addirittura crede che il proprio
desiderio sia fare quel lavoro per la
vita ostinata obbedienza a tutto ciò che
è costruito per ciascun essere umano
singolarmente preso e dunque è difficile
liberarsi da uno stato di minorità
divenuto gli quasi natura è giunto
perfino ad amarla e di fatto è
effettivamente incapace di servirsi
della sua propria intelligenza non
essendo gli mai stato consentito di
metterla alla prova ci dimentichiamo chi
eravamo e chi saremmo voluti diventare
iniziando quindi a definire intorno a
noi dei limiti col tempo lasciamo che ci
venga ha cucito addosso un modo di
vivere e di essere che molto spesso
sentiamo non appartenerci uno dei motivi
per cui è così difficile crescere liberi
e senza pregiudizi e che fin da piccoli
veniamo bombardati di insegnamenti su
chi che cose come dovremmo essere ad
esempio noi bambine più siamo belle più
ci sentiamo dire brava come se essere
brave dipendesse da quanto siamo belle i
maschietti non devono essere coccolati
troppo oppure crescono deboli ma che bel
bambino tuo figlio è un peccato che sia
disabile non si direbbe
poi col tempo non facciamo altro che
continuare a modellare la nostra vita e
la nostra forma in modo da farci
ricevere più complimenti possibili ma
non vestirti de rosa o sei gay e gay si
sa non sono uomini non vorrei mai essere
al suo posto
diventiamo la forma dei complimenti che
riceviamo credendo poi che quello sia il
nostro modo di essere il nostro essere
sei un uomo devi essere forte
non puoi farti mettere i piedi in testa
noi al lavoro e loro a causa con di
invalidità e il ponteggio gratis la
nostra vita si plasma su questo il
colore dei capelli il taglio i vestiti
lo sport è eccessivo i disturbi
alimentari e le operazioni rimodellanti
la creazione di una noi stessa che parte
dalla superficie invece che da dentro
mostri tuoi sentimenti sei un debole sei
una femminuccia meglio rinchiuderle che
foglio andora in giro
siamo prigionieri dei luoghi comuni un
vero maschio non piange non chiede scusa
un vero maschio piace a tutti sì un'alfa
comportati come una persona normale
diventiamo adulti impacchettati
cresciamo in questo mondo pieno di
pregiudizi creati dagli altri e da noi
stessi perché anche noi finiamo per
crederci
finiamo perché perché tutto ciò che
abbiamo sentito dire sia vero è che se
non saremo in un certo modo non saremo
mai accettati che se proveremo a fare di
testa nostra o intraprendere un percorso
inesplorato finiremo per fallire
finiremo per sentirci dire te lo avevo
detto e ci sarà capitato a volte di fare
quello che ci avevano sconsigliato e ci
sarà capitato a volte di cadere
tanto da non provarci più tanto da
sentirci dei falliti tanto da finire per
crederci limitati non usiamo più andare
oltre
abbiamo paura diventare autonomo ma se
autistico vorrei diventare un cantante
lirico
sì ma ce la fa uno su un milione dubbio
no ho detto oh sorgenti
incredibile
incredibile straordinario bravissimo ce
l'ha fatta anche se autistico un uomo
senza possibilità quando succede
facciamo un grande applauso lo guardiamo
e iniziamo a pensare bravissimo ma è
stato aiutato per lui le cose sono più
semplici
queste cose capitano solo agli altri
quadri con quello di febbraio fine di un
limite e renderlo un vantaggio ci
dimentichiamo che fino a poco fa era
accanto a noi ci sembra una cosa
incredibile
fuori dal comune ma se ci pensiamo
tutto ciò che ci sembra straordinario
incredibile che supera i limiti è
qualcosa che esce dagli schemi che esce
dal percorso che crediamo sia stato
disegnato per noi
incredibile e chi prende la strada che
più gli piace
e così va oltre ci segue il suo cammino
il fatto è che se guardiamo con
attenzione non è che ci manchino le
possibilità ma il nostro problema sta
nel credere che la nostra strada sia già
segnata segnata dai parenti dai genitori
dai nostri compagni dai nostri
professori delle superiori da che ci sta
attorno è segnata addirittura dal
giudizio di chi non conosciamo
siamo così incastrati in alcuni schemi
che spesso non ci rendiamo conto di
quanto in realtà siamo liberi di
decidere noi stessi cosa fare della
nostra vita
non è vero che non possiamo fare
altrimenti
non è vero che siamo prigionieri ci
sentiamo maledettamente prigionieri ma
non lo siamo noi siamo singole entità
noi siamo liberi di scegliere e decidere
in ogni momento in ogni singolo istante
sia per il bene che per il male
indipendentemente da quello che gli
altri dicono pensano oppure credono di
noi sembra piuttosto banale la frase che
in tanti dicono forse più per sentito
dire che per una
per analisi del suo significato
l'importante è essere se stessi così
banale eppure così vera non perché
essere se stessi significa avere tutte
le strade spianate si può comunque non
piacere a tante persone ma perché essere
se stessi significa capire cosa si vuole
davvero dalla propria vita capire dove
si vuole arrivare
oppure che tipo di persona vogliamo
essere prendere tutte le decisioni per
diventare quella persona e si essere
felici le persone straordinarie non sono
persone comuni che fanno cose fuori dal
comune
le persone straordinarie e felici sono
quelle che seguono da propria strada e
il proprio cuore perché per quanti
limiti gli altri possano vedere noi per
quanto possano sembrare reali gli unici
veri limiti sono quelli che costruiamo
noi stessi con la nostra mente nostro
dove lungo fa il primo passo
tutti lo sto così dove però tutti gli
ostacoli dovesse o vedendo il mio sogno
io proverò seguito
[Musica]
è
[Applauso]